كل سنه وانتم طيبين ويا رب دايما كده نبقى
سوا سوا على الهوا
اذا كنت تعرف
الرقم الان
احييكم اجمل تحيه وادعوكم لسماع باقه
جديده من اغنيتكم محاوله الاتصال في وقت
لاحق
[موسيقى]
انا سهير البدراوي المذيعه في اذاعه
الشباب والرياضه من القاهره
[موسيقى]
ويمكن سمعته صوتي في حاجات كتير قوي من
زمان في الكرتون ودلوقتي في الكرتون وكمان
في مترو الانفال استني بقى لما اقول حاجه
الله وبعدين يا حسونه هو كل حاجه تقول
استني استني اه اه ما انا عايزه اقول لهم
وانت طبعا يا بكار
هتذاكر وتحل الواجب وتيجي تقعد على باب
المدرسه لغايه ما تفتح اه ما انا عارفك اه
امال ايه طب ما فيش شخصيات تانيه كتير
عايزه تقول
اوهو مش معقول يا حسونه كفايه بقى سيبني
اقدم حاجه حتى مدام نفاخه كمان جت طيب يلا
بقى لا يا سبونج بوب لا تلمسها لا
قصتي مع صوت بدات من وانا في
اولى ابتدائي مع دخول المجال الاعلامي
بوجه عام من خلال برامج الاطفال ومن خلال
الدراما التلفزيونيه عاداته وتقاليد وبعد
كده بقى بسم الله ما شاء الله ما تعدش
والدتي كانت مخرجه في التلفزيون فكنت بروح
معها كنت ببقى فرحانه قوي كطفله بتروح
تتفرج وابتديت بقى اقدم مع ماما سميحه
وبعدها شاركت في عاداته وتقاليد
وفي برنامج رساله مع فايزه واصف وبعدها
شاركت مع ابله فضيله حبيبتي برضو حبايبي
الحلوين
كان يا مكان في سهل في الازمان اميره من
الاميرات كانت كل شويه ايام تتكلم كلام
وتامر امر لما كنت بعمل اعلانات كانوا
بيعرفوا الصوت ويجوا بقى يسالوني يا ترى
دي كويسه اقول لهم والله العظيم ما شفتها
يعني انا بعمل اعلان ما شفتش طقم الحلل
البايركس عشانك وعشان ولادك وعشان حماتك
ما شفتش انا بشتغل وخلاص اول جمله سجلتها
كانت من سنين كتير حوالي 3 سنين يعني كنا
عاملين في دلفي
مسلسل ديلفي هو من الحيوانات البحريه اللي
كنا بنمثلها ولكن انا لا نريد ان نفعل ذلك
شاركوا سياكلنا احترسوا من شاركوا
اه ولدي حبيبي يجب ان نحضر له كره اخرى من
الصعب انه هديه ديلفي في ذكر اقرب صوت
لصوتي هو يا بكار يا ولدي انا كنت قلقانه
عليك اتاخرت ليه قل يا بكار انت ما كنتش
بتذاكر قبل كده انا عارفه انك بتذاكر على
طول طبعا عرفتوا دي مين دي ام بكار اللي
عملتها في اول حاجه في الفيلم بتاع بكار
مع دكتوره حبيبه قلبي الجميله الفنانه
الدكتوره منى ابو النصر كايرو كرتون
وبعدها استمريت مع المخرج ابنها شريف جمال
وقدمنا بقى بعد بعد ما قدمنا فيلم بكار
وخد جوائز كتير قوي ابتدينا بقى نفكر اننا
نعمل مسلسل
منصور وصور السن وعارف معنى انه من قلبه
روحه مصري واني لقوه بيسري تاريخ اردو
بلادو بيجري جوه دم بكار كان لازم طفل
وكان كل ما بيكبر الطفل اللي بيقدم بكار
كنا دكتوره منى استاذ شريف بيعملوا كاستنج
ويمتحنوا اطفال ونحجز استوديو ويبتدوا
يختاروا حسونه ده بقى كان ظهر مع فارس
وهمام فكانوا عايزين طفل يليق على حسونه
فعملنا كاستنج ما حدش نجح فيه لحد ما ني
جيت وعملت حسونه وكان حلو قوي قوي وانا
حبيته عشان الجثه بتاعته ههه لو كنت وافقت
من الاول انك تغششني ما كانش المدرس خد
باله لكن ازاي لازم تعمل نفسك امين على
حسابي انا صاحبك المخلص اوعى تكلمني تاني
رشيده
[تصفيق]
لا طبعا ما اقدرش انسى الجده بخيته عايزه
حاجه تتبقى من الاكل ده ما تقلقيش يا جده
احنا بقى لنا اسبوع ما بناكلش يا فارس
اللي كانوا مع عم دهب وعم بطوط عم دهب
عمبب نريد ان نلعب
معك ده غير حسونه يعني ده في سنه
مناخيري يعني
[موسيقى]
عزيزي الراكب برجاء الالتزام بتعليمات
الهيئه العامه لمترو الانفاق مترو الانفاق
لكم وبكم حمل الله مصر وشعبها ورئيسها من
كل سوء الحكايه بدات في مترو الانفاق لما
الاستاذ احمد عبد الهادي بكير مدير
العلاقات العامه كلمني وقال لي نتقابل في
استوديو ديجيتال واضح ان في حد قال له علي
ورحت وابتدينا نسجل اول برومو لمترو
الانفاق الصوت مهم جدا في حياتي لانه هو
فعلا كل حياتي انا ما بقدرش اقعد من غير
ما اسجل من غير ما اشتغل حتى لو اشتغلت
بدون اجر ببقى سعيده لان انا ايه بحب
الحديده بحبها فالصوت مهم جدا يا رب احفظه
علي يا رب
حلو يا حلو رمضان كريم يا حاله حل الكيس
وادينا بقشيش لنروح منجيش يا حاله يعني ما
حدش حل الكيس هو ايه هو انا بقول لنفسي
حلو الكيس وادوني بقشيش
[موسيقى]